Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors here. Today we're going to talk about the
intestinal parasites. Now I do realize that this can be a hot topic in functional
medicine circles. Everybody's got parasites and you get to be careful with this
because just because you have GI symptoms does not mean you have parasites and you
may have GI symptoms and then jump right to doing a stool sample parisatology test
and it shows positive parasites and then you account for all your GI symptoms
to be due to those parasites. I'm going to warn you against that because usually
that's not the case. A lot of people have parasites and they don't need to treat
them. Now I do want to address this because if the you know you treated other
things in your gut, you dealt with the hypochloridory, you dealt with the leaky gut
issues, you dealt with the digestive abnormalities that have led to issues with
your seven phases of detoxification, your using binders, your clearing, your stool,
and you're still having issues, then you want to look at parisatology. Most
commonly it's a microbiota disturbance, it's a SIMO issue before its worms, okay?
But I'm not saying that it can't be. I've seen cases of parasites throughout
the history of my practice. I remember one gal came in with chronic migraines. Well
we tested her out with kinesiology. First tested out as trigonosis.
Trichonosis is what you get from raw pork. It's like this cannot be a
tested her multiple times. Put her on a supplement. It was actually paracler that we
used to try to knock that down. Sure, as we dug deeper into her history she said
oh my gosh I'd ever put these two things together but this all started after our
trip to Mexico nine months ago and we ate from a street vendor. I don't remember
the whole history but literally it doctor migraines out took care of them within a
week or so. So they can be persistent, they can be a problem. Of course in that
case it wasn't intestinal. It was it was systemic parasites and parasites in the
brain. This is going systemically are not that uncommon. But I also want to ward
against there's a lot of misinformation on Instagram and Facebook out there.
Especially we talk about cancer and I tell you how many people that I've spoken to
that think all cancers cause from parasites. That is just not true. So whatever
you say whenever you heard the all this all cancer all all people with this should
do this. You have to put up a red flag. Not that it's something or that nature might
not have some truth to it but you do have to put up a red flag. Never is all of
anything. Something you do want to investigate things individually. So I think it's
important to test for parasites but it should be a later stage that you test for. So
I just want to put that little caveat out there. So risk factors for intestinal
parasites. There's a lot of them and you know if you're exposed to farm
animals you're living outside. You have pets. Your dog glicks your kids face. You
know you're going to have parasitic infections that enter your body. And remember I
said the best cause the best proof and protection against orally based orally
entering parasites. Meaning you're getting them from your food. You're getting
them from your animal licking your face. You're getting them from your touching your
barnyard animals and their feces and then you're putting your figures to your
mouth or you're touching your food and then it's going into your mouth. The best
protection against orally based parasites. Parasites that are entering through
your mouth is a healthy hydrochloric acid production in your stomach. Do you
go back and listen to the HCl videos. So that is so so paramount. That's why I say
I don't think I have any business in testing for intestinal parasites until you
dealt with some of the upstream digestive issues first. Okay, it's just by
little another caveat. So foreign travel. Like by example, the gal who didn't even
put two and two together or her migrates. How could that be parasites? Well, I
throw it up. I don't have digestive issues. And then put it all together when I
stated that it could be from undercooked pork. Drinking untreated water or you
know, that isn't sanitary. Giardia, common parasite that you see with hikers, people in
the wild. Consumption of raw meat and fish. Hey, I love sushi. Better be taking some
HCl's on or clear digest time when I mean sushi because you want to make sure that
your HCl in your stomach is, you know, high concentration, very low pH in your
stomach. So you're killing anything that you're getting from that. There's
different types of parasites that end up creating problems. The most common
type, the most common parasite, which really isn't a parasite. It's a
bacterial infection to be H. Pylori. And then there's different signs of
parasite infections. You can stop the video and read this. I'm not going to
just read the slide. Intestinal parasites from a functional blood chemistry
analysis pattern. You'd see an increase in the eocidophils. Now, where are you
going to see eocidophils and basophils and monocytes on a CBC, a complete
blood count with differentials? You'll see an increased eocidophils,
increased basophils and increased monocytes. If you see this pattern with a patient,
then it may be a good idea. If you haven't addressed all the things that I've
already mentioned in this video, maybe a good idea to do a comprehensive stool
analysis test with parasitology. We use mosaic diagnostics for that.
This is just a screenshot of one page and it gets into detail. That's why I like
their lab. It gives you digestive and absorption of nutrient analysis because
it's measuring different things. It gives you just... I'm not going to read all
this. You can pause that. It really gives you a good picture of what's going
out of the gut. Again, it's not perfect. Like any test you look at the big picture.
You don't just go off that test and think that, oh, my whole goal is life is just to kill
these parasites. And once I kill these parasites, my health is going to come back into order
because usually parasites are there because of other dysfunctions.
So you got to... the parasites are typically not the bottom line cause.
So you have to get to that bottom line cause, heal the gut, heal the microbiota,
the gut, heal the HCL digestive enzyme issues, and bring that into balance so parasites can't
live and, you know, prolifer, or just grow like crazy in your gut when you have a healthy gut.
So we're going to work on those things as well. So continue to study, continue to learn.
And again, you can make an appointment if you need to and we go over this individually.
All right, thanks. God bless. Bye.